like this altitude I can run flat out
for a half-mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also your personal
question
now it is seen
I must - this episode is brought to you
by element spelled LM NT what on earth
is element it is a delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix I've stocked up on
boxes and boxes of this it was one of
the first things that I bought when I
saw cope it coming down the pike and I
usually use 1 to 2 per day element is
formulated to help anyone with their
electrolyte needs and perfectly suited
to folks following a keto low-carb or
paleo diet or if you drink a ton of
water and you might not have the right
balance that's often when I drink it or
if you're doing any type of endurance
exercise mountain biking etc another
application if you've ever struggled to
feel good on keto low-carb or paleo it's
most likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone bla bla bla
and insulin is low but suffice to say
this is where element again spelled lmn
t can help my favorite flavour by far is
citrus salt which is a side note you can
also use to make a kick-ass no sugar
margarita but for special occasions
obviously you're probably already
familiar with one of the names behind it
Rob Wolfe ro BB Rob Wolfe who is a
former research biochemist and two-time
New York Times bestselling author of the
Paleo solution and wired to eat Rob
created element by scratching his own
itch that's how it got started his
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu coaches turned him
on to electrolytes as a performance
enhancer things clicked and bam company
was born so if you're on a low-carb diet
or fasting electrolytes play a key role
in relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring all that's garbage
unneeded there's none of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element whose
recommend to be by one of my favorite
athlete friends three Navy SEAL Teams as
prescribed by their Master Chief Marine
units FBI sniper teams at least 5 NFL
teams who have subscriptions they are
the exclusive hydration partner to Team
USA weightlifting and
and on you can try it risk-free if you
don't like it element will give you your
money back no questions asked they have
extremely low return rates so again
element element II came up with a very
special offer for you guys they've
created Tim's club just go to drink
element dot-com slash Tim select
subscribe and save and use promo code
Tim's club to get the 30 count box of
element for only $36 this will be valid
for the lifetime of the subscription and
you can pause at any time so again check
it out it's drink
LM and tea calm slash Tim for this
exclusive offer using promo code
Tim's Club one more time drink LM NT
element so drink LM NT calm / Tim and
promo code
Tim's Club check it out this episode is
brought to you by five bullet Friday my
very own email newsletter it's become
one of the most popular email
newsletters in the world with millions
of subscribers and it's super super
simple
it does not clog up your inbox every
Friday I send out five bullet points
super short of the coolest things I've
found that week which sometimes includes
apps books documentaries supplements
gadgets new self experiments hacks
tricks and all sorts of weird stuff that
I dig up from around the world
you guys podcast listeners and book
readers have asked me for something
short and action-packed for a very long
time because after all the podcast the
books they can be quite long and that's
why I created five bullet Friday it's
become one of my favorite things I do
every week it's free it's always gonna
be free and you can learn more at Tim
blog forward slash Friday
that's tim dot blog forward slash friday
I get asked a lot how I meet guests for
the podcast some of the most amazing
people I've ever interacted with and a
little known fact I've met probably 25%
of them because they first subscribed to
500 Friday so you'll be in good company
it's a lot of fun five bullet Friday is
only available if you subscribe via
email
I do not publish the content on the blog
or anywhere else also if I'm doing small
in-person meetups offering early access
to startups beta testing special deals
or anything else that's very limited I
share it first with 500 Friday
subscribers
so check it out Tim vlog forward slash
Friday if you listen to this podcasts
very likely that you'd dig it a lot and
you can of course easily subscribe any
time so easy peasy again that's Tim blog
forward slash Friday and thanks for
checking it out
if the spirit moves yeah hello boys and
girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show my guest today
I'm gonna keep my usual preamble short
is someone who has impressed me
incredibly over the last few years and
that is Jim death mur de th m ER jim is
one of the world's leading voices on
conscious leadership we'll explain what
that means he is a co-founder at
conscious leadership group CLG website
conscious dot I is co-author of the
number one best-selling book on
conscious leadership the fifteen
commitments of conscious leadership an
international speaker and has advised
hundreds of CEOs and their teams to
eliminate drama and build trust now just
to be clear for those people who are
thinking I don't have time for that
right now we are going to dig into tools
and frameworks that can be applied also
on the individual family and other unit
levels so this is not limited to
business and that's actually where my
interest in Jim began top hedge fund
managers heads of major hospital systems
tech leaders elite thought leaders YPO
chapters and forums all rely on Jim's
wisdom and guidance to become highly
self-aware and create conscious cultures
that can also and I'm adding a lot of
subtext here be within the home not
necessarily within a large office or
organization currently Jim's focus is on
working with the most devoted conscious
leaders with particular interest in
those leading underserved populations
and training the next generation of
conscious leadership coaches Jim lives
in Chicago with his wife Debbie I hope
to talk about their relationship
actually or ask about it and part time
in their souls home in Michigan one of
my favorite places where he recharges
playing golf and delighting in the roles
of father and grandfather you can find
Jim and the conscious leadership group
on Facebook at conscious leadership
group on Twitter conscious l.g
didn't conscious - leadership - group
and on YouTube at conscious is now on
the website as I mentioned before is
conscious dot I is Jim welcome to the
show help Tim great to be with you and
you and I have a fair amount of
background we at least initially
unbeknownst to me at least have quite a
few mutual friends including a number of
past guests on this podcast and I hope
we get to explore all sorts of corners
and nooks and crannies that can bring
sort of disproportionate joy and impact
to people who are listening I think we
can do that and I thought we would start
with perhaps just providing a little bit
of background on Jim before he became
Jim as described in the bio would you be
willing to share just a bit of your own
background and you can choose to answer
that however you like mmm yeah I believe
so probably the way I would describe it
and this will be germane to a lot of
what we talk about is that from the time
I was a little kid I have been a seeker
largely driven at first by a literal
physical ache in the center of my chest
probably if I would have been clinically
diagnosed I was probably sub clinically
depressed much of my life so there was
like a yearning a longing and that drove
me to seek out you know some of the best
teachers and greatest modalities for
giving somebody some peace for all of my
life I was seeking peace or happiness or
equanimity and then the second thing you
would know about me is that based on my
family of origin and some of the
craziness that went on there I've always
been interested in relationships again
largely trying to resolve the loneliness
the
I felt so those two things kind of an
existential angst mild depression and
loneliness drove me not on the outside I
was a you know normally put together
person and you know succeeded and
achieved and did all that stuff but
underneath I was a seeker and it drove
me to find relief quite frankly which
for which I'm incredibly incredibly
grateful and then the second thing you'd
know about because when I find cool
stuff I pass it on so I say all the time
I don't think I've ever had an original
thought
there's nothing original in our book on
our website anyplace maybe once in
awhile I accidentally put something
together but it would be accidental most
everything that I found I found from
somebody else and I loved to pass it on
and the last thing you'd learn is I'm a
smuggler so a lot of the places I've
gone and explored a lot of the people
who I've worked with over the years
wouldn't go there and explore so I go
out and find these modalities these
technologies of transformation and then
I'm pretty good at translating them into
language that an end user would find
viable and credible so I smuggle these
things into populations who wouldn't
otherwise necessarily go looking so
that's a little bit about me that maybe
you we could find some points of contact
I would love to I have already made
contact and there are a few places I'd
like to dig and before I do so I'll just
give a bit more context on how you
entered my orbit and the first way that
you entered my orbit was actually
through Dustin Moskovitz the co-founder
of Facebook who recommended the 15
commitments of conscious leadership this
book and I'm not gonna lie it took me a
while to actually pick it up and read it
because I have had perhaps an unfair
bias against anything with the title
leadership or involving the word
leadership but as you as you mentioned
with the smuggling I think your your
arena is much broader than
that or perhaps it just requires a
reinterpretation of leadership the way
that one of my friends described you and
this friend is is a very very successful
investor one of the best investors who's
been on this podcast and he says quote I
think if Jim is a spiritual equivalent
of a world champion MMA fighter he takes
the best of everyone else's practices
and integrates them for himself and
others so I thought we could use that
just as a jumping off point to an
example or he could get into some some
brass tacks tactical stuff and the
question actually will dig into a
specific person and that is Byron Katie
and so this this friend says that you're
exceptionally good at finding high
credibility gurus various types and then
as you said smuggling their techniques
or using reapplying you were very early
as I understand it in terms of
identifying Byron Katie and then kind of
soaking up what she does
grabbing the essence of it and applying
it in multiple places so this is a long
question but could you I suppose explain
who Byron Katie is and then how you
identified her as someone worth spending
time with because we all we all have a
limited number of hours and finite
amount of energy and then what you have
taken from Byron as one example mmm okay
beautiful if it's okay I want to do it
in reverse order let me
great so you how I identified her then
tell you my experience of her and then
what I've taken from it so again I'm 66
and I started this quest of seeking when
I was like 15 and a long ago I have
found these master teachers like Byron
Katie and when I look back if I were to
deconstruct the pattern what has
happened is I find people who are
aligned with my personal need go back to
bein in the center of my chest
depression existential angst or
loneliness so I'm pretty good at
refining my search down to people who
are going to
speak to and address those needs then
the second thing that's true and this
has been through all of my life I get
drawn to people who make a big claim
they they they state something that on
its face seems too good to be true like
in Byron Katie's case she states that
suffering is optional
now I think she would understand what
the Buddhists have said his suffering is
natural and normal it's the water in
which we swim and then suffering is
optional so I'm drawn to a big claim all
of my teachers and mentors make a big
claim the next thing I'm drawn to is an
incredibly simple process a lot of
people make big claims but then you get
involved and the process of accessing
the claim is so damn complicated that I
get lost so we can look at by Arcadia in
just a minute but in the in the midst of
the incredible information and process
and present she's brought forward into
the world her entire work boils down to
four questions and a couple of
turnarounds that's something I can write
on a three by five card and turn it into
a daily if not hourly practice then the
next thing that's sure about everybody
that I go after is I am drawn to people
who are authentic real transparent I've
got a pretty quick hypocrisy sniffer
largely because I've spent time in my
life being hypocritical and so I have
dealt with all of that and I can smell
it in other places so and then the last
thing I do is once I find somebody I
dive in so I find their model and I dive
in and we could pick different people
throughout her talk but Byron Katie
would be a great example so I read her
books I listened to her on tape on her
books on tape and then I go to her
website I digest it and then literally I
turn it into a practice
so Katy is famous for what is called
inquiry and inquiry as we said are just
four simple questions you take any
thought and you begin with disturbing or
stressful thoughts and in this period
that we're in now most of our minds are
filled with disturbing and stressful
thoughts and the first thing you do is
you write the thought down you just
write it down and then you ask it for
questions
is it true can I know for certain it's
true when I believe the thought how do I
react and who would I be without the
thought and one thing that I learned
early and that I say to people who are
embarking on doing any work around the
work as Katie calls it is that it's not
an intellectual exercise you don't just
ask those questions to your mind and
real quick answers it's it's much much
more like a meditation so you take a
stressful thought you write it down and
then you remember a circumstance where
that thought was at play
so I'll give one today would be an
example before we connected I was out
for my morning walk and I had a
stressful thought arising around one of
our kids my daughter is today scheduled
to go to Northwestern Hospital in
Chicago to get an x-ray she had spinal
fusion surgery and she's going in to get
an x-ray so she can talk to her
specialist about whether the surgery
worked well I started stressing myself
around the thought she shouldn't be
going to the hospital to have an x-ray
and I could feel myself you know my
nervous system was getting activated and
I could feel it in my body so then it's
an opportunity for me to simply do the
meditation
so I think the thought she shouldn't be
going to the hospital then I asked is it
true and I meditate on that I let the
answers come to me then can I know for
certain it's true then this next
question if I couldn't think that
thought how would I be well what a
arises fairly quickly is peaceful
present available to her available to
really see her and talk to her so and
when I think the thought how do I react
well I get scared contracted I start
trying to control the world so again the
technology is so simple it can be
written on a card and practiced so that
would be an example with Byron K so in
my mind she is a transmitter of
liberation and freedom with an
unbelievable ly simple way to get at it
now simple and profound in that you know
it's not a it's like so many of these
things it's simple and transformational
e profound if you do the work like she
says all the time you know you work the
work til the work works you so I started
with my McKay T years ago and you match
up and Jim for one second yes yeah so
I'd love to expand on that just for a
second for people who haven't had
exposure to Byron Katie before in an
example like that and for those people
who are listening to this later and
hopefully this context is needed sooner
rather than later but the concern about
the hospital's related to two SARS cough
two and covered 19 is the objective in
that example to down-regulate your
system so that you can make a calmer
decision about what needs to be done or
not done in the sense that I could
imagine people some people listening or
thinking well you should be looking for
alternatives that's a legitimate concern
so you don't want to dismiss it and
would this exercise not lead you to
dismiss it does that make sense
absolutely and so I'd love to hear how
it's an enabling tool or a tool that
makes you
more I hesitate uses word but effective
instead of complacent does that does
that make sense and this is actually
something that comes up a fair amount
with some of Byron Katie's techniques
which can be extremely powerful I mean
I've seen people reframe the death of a
parent in ways that completely changed
their lives in fifteen or twenty minutes
in the sense that they might take a
phrase right like she doesn't need to go
to the hospital and then rephrase it as
Byron Katie does or she does need to go
to the hospital I need to go to the
hospital I and so on and so forth and
look for evidence or be forced to give
evidence for each of those sort of
conjugated statements which is something
else so I don't want to take us off
topic but how would you speak to the
fear that someone listening to this
example thinks it would just make you
complacent and that you should in fact
consider other options yeah great so let
me start up late like it the highest
level and then I want to come down to
the incredibly practical level of my
experience so at the highest level I
think what Katie is she is called is
going that is the possibility of freedom
the possibility of truly being free from
being trapped in and suffering at the
effect of the perseveration of the mind
and all the suffering that comes there
so now if you could if you drop down a
level yes one of the outcomes is
down-regulating the system so what we're
looking at here is doing a practice like
this allows me to become present fully
present so there's so many definitions
of consciousness so many wonderful ones
we use a very practical one it's just
the ability to be here now in a non
triggered nonreactive way so that I can
think better relate better and have
better intuitive information so be here
now in a non triggered nonreactive way
so that I can have better IQ think about
her EQ emotional intelligence and B Q
body intelligence better instinctual
intuitive now
so all that to say it's misunderstood
and misused when people use it as I like
the term like a spiritual bypass I mean
the reality is that at least when the
morning started my daughter is going to
go to the hospital and get an x-ray
that's the plan
that's really happening at least it
appears to be happening we'll see
because she hasn't gone yet
so from this activated place or in our
language we use this simple term from
below the line triggered reactive
contracted and threatened fear there's a
limited amount of capacity for
decision-making for innovation for
problem-solving so Katie's work to your
point down regulates it doesn't allow me
to bypass reality and just kind of sit
in a disengaged demotivated kind of you
know way it actually frees me to be
totally available to what are the
possibilities that I wouldn't otherwise
see because of the contraction and
constrain of my activated thinking that
is the exact purpose so after I did the
work I called my daughter and first and
foremost was able to be present with her
and then I'm living in what is it that
wants to happen here and you know in
just chatting with you a few minutes
before we even started you had a couple
of ideas that came and became
possibilities that weren't possibilities
before so it it isn't to be naive it
isn't to be complacent fact I find that
people who are more present are less
complacent complacency is one of the
actual effects of not being fully
present it's an escape move
but people who are fully present are
everything but complacent they are they
have all energy available and at rest
for action that needs to be taken that's
a big statement but does that get a
little bit at what you're pointing at
him oh it totally does and and I think
you described it very well it's
something that I struggled with even in
the beginning with meditation I and many
of my friends also were afraid of losing
their edge that was the phrase that was
used most often and my experience has
been that many of these tools these
modalities don't cause you to lose your
edge although I'm sure that you could
there are many ways to become complacent
but they do in effect help you to turn
down the volume of static so that you
can hear the signal and the various
types of signals so I agree and I think
that the the the underscoring of
complacency as an example of non
presence is very important could we also
talk to and this won't just be a list of
influences but I do think that it's
helpful to give a few examples gay
Hendricks who is gay Hendricks and maybe
you could speak to sort of his audacious
claims or claim and run it through the
same framework as you did with Katy if
you would have like beautiful if it's
okay I just want to go back and grab one
thread for a moment about its
complacency one of the things I've
observed in myself and then others that
I taught too is that actually when
somebody starts to do something like
meditation or the work by Byron Katie or
these other modalities there is often
not always but often a period where
something that looks like complacency
does emerge
and I think there are many reasons for
that but one of them is that a lot not
all but a lot of high performers are
motivated by some sort of fear at the
core of their being and that and that
motivation has served them very very
well the fear of a loss of approval or
control or security like a primal
instinctual thing and a lot of the most
achievement-oriented successful people
have a large engine of fear sitting in
there so when you start dealing with
that one of the things that they're
going to face is if I'm not motivated
either consciously or unconsciously by
the things that have motivated me
whether it's fear or you know extrinsic
reward or things like that what am I
going to be motivated by and I think
that is a really important question for
people to explore and discuss and in my
experience other forms of motivation
come online like creativity like
playfulness like love there's a whole
set of motivations that are actually
incredibly powerful and don't leave much
of a toxic residue like fear or guilt or
shame does but there is sometimes a gap
so when I'm talking to people and I say
now listen if you're gonna start to do
some of these things and unwind some of
your core motivations we're going to
need to anticipate that there might be a
period where you're gonna be in no man's
land and you're gonna go holy [ __ ] I've
lost my mojo yeah and and then it's can
we trust that something else is going to
emerge which will be equally if not even
more motivational and leave less of a
toxic residue personally and
relationally so I just want to say that
before I talk about gay
no I I appreciate that that's a really
important point and I also experienced
that I mean there's a period of time
it's not necessarily years and years and
years not necessarily months and months
and months but it could be a there is a
gap period where the cars in the shop
and the transmissions getting replaced
so to speak and you're not gonna be
travelling very quickly while that is
happening necessarily so thank you for
backtracking and he's pausing to
describe that yeah thank you so let's
talk about gay Hendricks and his wife
Katy so game Katy Hendricks I found my
way to gauge shortly after Debbie and I
got together so Deb and I had been
together for about 25 years we just saw
our celebrate our 20th anniversary we've
known each other since we were 15 but we
were married to other people and then
found our way back to each other and
just after a short period of time being
married Debbie said hey I'd like to go
to one of these gay and Katy Hendricks
workshops and we read one of their books
a book I recommend countlessly to people
called conscious loving and so we went
to one of their workshops by the way it
was at that workshop that I met my
partner who you know Diana Chapman she's
great and I sat now this now we'll go
back to the same thing so I sat in the
room with gay and Katy and here was one
of their big claims one of their phrases
that they taught me was zone of genius I
love that phrase they're expert in this
idea of helping people live and work and
be from their zone of genius but one of
their zones of genius is human
relationships at all levels but
especially intimate relationships I'll
never forget Deb and I were to workshop
in Ojai California and in the first few
hours gay makes this preposterous
statement it's been like I think he said
15 years since Katie and I had a drama
based fight now that doesn't mean they
don't have healthy conflict if you if
people know these two they are not
drinking wallflowers they are powerful
live vital co-creative people but they
had removed from their relationship the
toxic energy of blame and criticism so
it's been years since we had a drama
based fight and we no longer blame and
criticize and I thought you gotta be
kidding me
that was the preposterous claim and then
they said and there are a couple of
simple tools so that met my next
criteria preposterous claim simple tool
and as I got and deadly nine apprentice
in with them they're just as authentic
and real and I had my sniff test out
four years are they bullshitting is this
manufactured I couldn't find it so
Debbie and I dove into the simple tools
in terms of our relationship and I'd say
it's one of the primary reasons we have
what I would call an exquisite
relationship to this day so gay and Katy
are experts at world-class relationships
breathing no small thing in this day and
age by the way breathing embodiment
living in your body and living
discovering and living in your zone of
genius now they do a lot of other stuff
but what I have taken and continue to
take from them and smuggle and transport
out to the world is legion in these
regards could you give a few examples of
tools or techniques that you think might
they don't necessarily have to apply
specifically to this quarantine period
that a lot of people are experiencing
but anything that comes to mind that you
could give or offer as specific
techniques or concepts that you found
particularly powerful from Gaye and
Katie Andrews well absolutely
[Music]
so the first but I start very basically
here and you know this and many people
listen this knows but we cannot be
reminded enough begin with breathing and
specifically conscious breathing
and one of the techniques gay taught us
was what he called a simple 4x4 breath
not turned into box breathing and things
like that but it's simply breathed with
a four-second inhale and a four-second
exhale breathe into the belly and bring
your attention to the breath so you feel
the breath going in going down the pause
in between the inhale and the exhale and
then you feel it come back out to the
pause and what it does and everybody
knows this is it changes your blood and
brain chemistry because when we're
activated you look at social media you
look at the news most of us are living
in a constantly activated state right
now so if we're willing and sometimes
we're not we get addicted to the
chemicals of this heightened state but
if we're willing to shift then breathing
is the first shift move for 4 by 4
breaths 32 seconds with your attention
on your breath so you don't do this
while thinking about the virus or while
thinking about the food you need in your
house or while thinking about your child
going to the hospital to get an x-ray
you bring your attention to the breath
and it equilibrate the system now there
are many many other breathing techniques
but that would be a huge one when you
think sorry to interrupt
when you this is my job as it's
interrupt I apologize - when you say
focus on the breath there are many
different ways to focus on the breath
could you describe how you focus on the
breath is it the air or the contact the
nostrils sort of air coming in air
coming out is it the belly how how do
you focus on the breath or direct
attention to the breath yeah so
beautiful well the first thing I want to
say to create the shift move it doesn't
really matter how you focus on the
breath know what I mean by that as you
could simply say where do I feel the
breath in the body so let's say you feel
the chest expanding and
you know you feel the belly rising and
falling or you feel the breath of the
tip of the nostrils or the back of the
throat you can feel it all the way
through and all the way back out for
this exercise the key is that you've
moved your attention from the worrying
mind to the breath it's the movement of
attention so I just say to people where
do you most feel the breath in the body
go there and Liat leave your attention
there for just 30 seconds and when it
wanders just bring it back
the combination of deepening the inhale
and the exhale breathing into the belly
put your hand on your belly at about
behind and see if you can move the
breath move the hand with the breath and
bringing your attention to it is an
instantaneous way to de-stress in the
moment that make sense it does weird you
tend to focus where do I tend to focus
it depends on what period of my life I'm
in so it right now the last week I good
so right now if I'm doing a breathing
exercise I focus at the top of my upper
lip the little triangle as the bottom of
my nose in the top of my upper lip where
I can do one of the reasons I focus
there is it really invites my
concentration I can feel my chest rise
and expand but if I'm gonna feel cool
air coming in and warm air going out and
I'm gonna feel it on my upper lip that
requires a level of concentration which
I like because it takes me away from my
cataclysmic thoughts yeah that's you
know I'd sort of mention one thought
that pop to mind that is a corollary to
that in marksmanship and whether it's
archery or using long guns or anything
else there's an expression which is
focused small miss small and what that
means is if your target in your mind is
something the size of a dinner plate
then you
often if you miss miss by a multiple of
the dinner plate but if you're focusing
on say a very small target a specific
tiny piece of bark or a tiny hair if
you're hunting for instance that you
will tend to miss by a smaller margin so
it makes a lot of sense that what you're
describing would hone the attention
because you have a smaller aperture
through which to focus if that makes any
sense yeah it's beautiful let me can I
give you a second way that the Hendrix
what I learned from game Katie yes Leeds
been transformational in the midst of
what we're all going through it was from
game Katie that I first learned how to
be with feelings States in a way that
was productive helpful in a way that
allowed me to not repress or suppress or
express in non-productive not effective
ways and in the midst of what we're
going through now I think a lot of
what's going on is people's feeling
states are greatly activated so there's
a lot of fear there's a lot of anger
there's a lot of sadness three core
emotions and generally speaking we don't
know how to be with feelings in a way
that allows them to do what feelings are
meant to do we're hardwired to have
feelings as mammals and most of us don't
know how to be with them especially
heightened or activated feelings so game
Katie and others have come up with
wonderful technologies for how to be
with feelings so if you're again getting
a download of information from whatever
source you're getting it and fear shows
up they taught us again an incredibly
simple way to be with feelings that
keeps you vital and alive and available
without being contracted in the feelings
so that would be another very meaningful
tool that they brought
Our Lives how do you do that what is the
what would be if somebody wanted to
practice this what would what might a
practice look like okay great I'll do it
as though someone is sitting here with
me I would say just begin by taking a
deep breath so you kind of get here just
one deep breath it doesn't have to be a
lot and then I would simply ask the
question what feeling is here now now to
help people answer that question we like
to give them a short list of possible
feelings because it makes answering very
simple so again I learned from game
Katie the five core feeling sad angry
scared joy and creative sexual feelings
let's just go with those is the five
core we could also talk about shame or
guilt things like that but if you just
go with the core five and then in this
day and age I like to simplify it down
to the core three sad angry scared so I
like to say to people before you can get
emotionally intelligent you have to be
emotionally literate which is just the
ability to pause and ask yourself what
am i feeling and have an answer that is
so important could you just repeat that
because I want you to say it as much for
me as for anyone else but I just think
that's such an eloquent way to state
something extremely important could you
Zann words mm-hmm before you can be
emotionally intelligent EQ you have to
be emotionally literate an emotional
literacy means that at any moment you
can pause and ask yourself what feeling
is here now and have an answer I learned
this when I first got married to my
first wife we were maybe a year into our
relationship and started to have
conflict so we went to a marriage
therapy and we're sitting in the office
I'll never forget this and the therapist
at one point says to me Jim what are you
feeling and I said a number statements I
think the first one was I feel like
she's wrong and then basically some
version of I feel like she's got her
head up her ass was basically and I'll
never forget that therefore saying those
aren't
those are thoughts anytime you say the
word I feel followed by the word that
it's not gonna be a feeling it's gonna
be a thought and I thought I was in the
midst of graduate school I thought I
have never heard that before so he asked
me again and again I answered it with
some sort of thought so I'll never
forget he turns around chair grabs a
book off the shelf I to this day
remember the title of the book he opened
the book handed it to me it was like
page 73 and Anna was a list of feelings
this is how unemotionally literate I was
by the way you know I was a meaningful
athlete I cared a lot about sports I
never had a high school football coach
say to me Jim what are you feeling right
now I mean feelings were at that point
meant to be irrelevant it was just
performance feelings were just a
distraction to performance by the way
some people still relate to them that
way and I think that's a dangerous
position so he hands me the book if he
says now any time I ask you what are you
feeling I want you to say I feel and
then answer it with one of these words
now there were a lot of words so that's
why I say what if it's just sad angry
scared now anger can be a big range it
can be a little bit irritated a little
bit agitated frustrated all the way over
to anger to rage for fear can be a
little bit apprehensive a little bit
nervous all the way over to fear or
terror we're just gonna call everything
on the continuum the fear and sadness
can be a little down the blue little
melancholy to sadness to brokenhearted
grief at the sake of learning we're just
gonna make it simple Sarah sad scared
angry so again if we back up I'd say
take a breath everybody takes a breath
and then I say in this moment what are
you feeling and if you check you go like
hmm I feel scared great just that
statement I feel scared starts to shift
the process because we've accessed a
different part of the brain that isn't
the amygdala that isn't in that fight
flight freeze reactive
that is the one who interprets and puts
it into language so if you say it out
loud or just say to yourself I feel
scared is the first step the second step
and this is where it gets really good is
you have to understand what is a feeling
such a good question when we could riff
on this for days but basically a feeling
is a set of vibrations or sensations in
or on the body usually combined with a
thought so there's a thought and there's
a feeling what we often call the
cognitive emotive loop but a feeling is
a set of sensations in and on the body
that's what it primarily is so the
second question we ask is first question
what feeling is here
fear now this is where it gets
interesting
where is the fear in the body and I work
with people all the time who don't
nothing about this but it's just
instinctual they go nuts in my belly
it's in the center of my chest it's in
my jaw it's great it's in my belly so
what's the feeling where is it then the
next question is what are the sensations
doing there
like there's nausea they're there
they're boiling roiling contracting
heating pulsing okay great so what's the
feeling fear where is it in my belly
what's happening then you're saying then
the next question is could you just
place your attention on the sensations
for a couple of moments and this is a
key tip because at this point it's a
kind of a subtle move to give the
feeling presence because again most of
us don't have
a healthy relationship with fear so when
fear comes up we repress it suppress it
or get paralyzed by it here we're just
letting fear be and you don't have to do
this for very long just for a couple of
moments could you just allow the belly
to gurgle if it's anger could you just
Allah they allow the heat in your face
if it's sadness could you just allow the
pressure and the eyes the tears and that
move of allow is what gets the energy
releasing when we repress or suppress
feelings they get stopped literally they
can get stopped for hours days months
years where pres viewings can turn into
moods and postures because we haven't
let them flow through the body these
feelings are made to come online course
through our body and if we were just
like your dog or my grandchildren below
the age of two they just feel the
feeling and it goes through in moments
at the most a minute minute and a half
it goes through and once it goes through
we're back into presence and then the
last step of emotional intelligence is
ask the feeling what's it here to show
you
so get real simple what feeling is here
name it I feel scared where is it in the
belly what's it doing gurgling roiling
pulsing pumping heating twisting could I
just allow it could I just give it
attention and let it be like with fear
you know the antidote to fear is
acceptance when my grandkids are scared
I don't say to them hey there's nothing
to be scared about stop being scared
first thing I do and I got this from Dan
Siegel and his marvelous work is I
breathe then I sit and I get present
with my grandchildren
and I say Oh sweetie you're scared it's
okay to be scared grandfather gets
scared all the time and by that act of
acceptance and then just maybe hey could
we just breathe together for a minute
you and me or if they're an anger I
might say would you want to just beat a
bag for a second you know take your
little bat and hit a chair so you'd get
it out of your body and when feelings
are met with acceptance they just
naturally release they don't cause us
all kinds of you know somatic struggles
the rest of our lives they don't destroy
relationships and then once the fear has
been you know released from the body
then we ask the emotion like the purpose
of fear is to teach us to pay attention
or wake up that's what fear does so you
just ask Wow fear came into my body what
am I being invited to pay attention to
with anger angers inviting us to see
that something isn't of service and it
needs to be stopped angers the energy of
stop or boundaries sadness is something
needs to be grieved or let go of so this
is I learned this from Jane Katie and it
changed my life and it changed our
marriage you know one of our commitments
in our marriages we commit to feel all
of our feelings and we say we commit to
feel all of our feelings all the way
through to completion and we commit to
support the other person to feel their
feelings so if Debbie is having a
feeling I don't say Oh Deb stop but I
don't try to fix it the first thing I do
is I just breathe and I say what
feelings here where is it can we just be
with it I'll just sit with you while you
feel you're feeling by the way this
produces tremendous closeness and
connection so I'll pause there cuz again
I've said a lot Tim and I imagine that
brings up something for you or some
point of clarification or our story how
this shows up for you it does I don't
even though just despite the
narcissistic name of my podcast Tim
Ferriss show I don't want to dominate
the conversation but I it
it does bring a number of things to mind
I would say that the first is an insight
one of the more important insights that
I've had over the last 10 years which
came in a non-ordinary
state which we may or may not get into
but it's it's not necessary to be in
altered states to have this type of
insight and that was for me it came as a
simple statement and the statement was
you don't find peace through
understanding you find peace through
acceptance now that can be I'll repeat
it then I'm gonna provide some context
so you don't find peace through
understanding you find peace through
acceptance the context is number one I
think this applies to many people it
applies to me and this was a
personalized statement it was in
reference to me in my life is that I
think for people who are very thought
dominant and have been sort of rational
logical language data-driven for a long
time of myself in that camp someone who
like you for a long time
viewed emotions and feelings as at best
a distraction and more often as a
handicap or liability that if we could
think our way out of our suffering we
would have done it by now if that is our
if that is our most over developed and
overused muscle and that for me at least
the the greater opportunity is to accept
as many things as possible that this is
the this is the caveat that enable me
and don't disable me so this doesn't
mean you simply become a piece of
driftwood getting thrown around in the
rapids of life I've been crunching
numbers and looking at endless hours of
data which over the last eight weeks at
least that have been very very very
critical for decision making so I
haven't just become a passive actor in
life but if I'm looking at my own
sources of suffering specifically and
the vast majority of which is
unnecessary or blown out of proportion
the path to peace for me is is more
acceptance not more understanding and
that I think comes at its core down to
accepting and feeling these emotions
that we might be prone to labeling as
negative mm-hmm for instance I've had
I've had a lot of difficulty with anger
in the last few days which I think on
some level is and I want to credit
Krista Tippett I believe who said this
has an incredible podcast called on
being for saying that anger is pain and
publicly so I think that my anger during
these times is very closely related to
fear and that just going through this
exercise with you and listening very
intently over the last few minutes has
allowed some of that to pass right it's
it's as though for much of my life when
I've had say terrifying thunder clouds
and lightning that pass overhead ice
encase it by resisting it I sort of
encase it in a glass bowl so that it
can't move and that for me at least it's
been tremendously enabling to accept
more and from there I would love to
segue to what seems to be a related
question and this is a question that I
believe you asked leaders different
people you work with and that is it's
it's one of several questions and I
believe there's an order to it and so
you can answer this any way you want but
the question is can you accept yourself
for being scared and below the line and
I would be curious to hear why you asked
that and what the importance of that is
and you you briefly described what below
the line means but what is the
importance of the question can you
accept yourself for being scared and
below the line okay great so yeah that's
the second question of for again our
attempt to distill the technology down
to something you could write on the back
of a three by five card so the first
question is very simple it's just where
are you
so in this now moment where are you and
the answer is either above the line or
below the line again above the line is
present available in a state of trust
below the line is in threat contract it
just where are you we call this the
context question how are you being with
the content of your life this is a big
distinction the content of life is
whatever is occurring you know if you
and I went out and had a beer together
and just talked we would talk about the
content of our life but we're committed
to the idea that context is equally if
not more important so where are you with
the content where am i with the content
of my daughter going to the hospital or
or where am i with the content of the
virus today or where am i with the
content of a technical glitch while
talking to you
where am i above or below line and often
you know we say probably 80% of the time
maybe more 90% of the time most of us
are belong line it's just a natural
human tendency to scan the world look
for threat and get reactive but the
question where are you brings awareness
we step outside of ourselves and we say
ah okay I'm reactive right now and then
the second question is can you accept
yourself for being reactive and it's
just like we were saying before usually
when we're reactive even though what
might be showing up is anger or sadness
or irritation or something like that
underneath were scared and scared of
losing one of the big three usually
approval control or security yeah I like
the idea I got this from Hale Dwoskin
and the Sedona Method all of us have
these three core wants wanting to be
approved of like loved valued wanting
control and wanting security so when
we're below the line we're experiencing
a threat to one or multiple of those
so where am i below the line and then
like we've said the antidote to that
threatened state is acceptance can you
just accept yourself for being scared
it's such a simple question and yet it's
first of all it requires that you're
willing to admit that you're triggered
and reactive and in a threatened State
and then could you accept yourself and
kind of like what you alluded to earlier
a lot of people can't accept themselves
for feeling what they're feeling they
think they shouldn't be scared or they
shouldn't be having the experience if
they were more mature or more
enlightened whatever they wouldn't have
the experience but that just causes us
to become more reactive so the second
question before is can you give yourself
just a breath of acceptance so that puts
it in context and the third question is
are you willing to shift and the shift
areas are you willing to be with the
same content content is gonna stay the
same from above the line and then the
fourth question is how are you gonna
shift so that's our attempt to distill
this process down to four simple
questions and I'd like to focus which
may be a lesser way to focus but
nonetheless because we we are have been
talking about acceptance or willingness
to be with say how you're feeling and
this is something that I'm struggling
with right now so I'm gonna much like
you seek out your teachers for personal
reasons or from individual context I'm
gonna do that right now
so hopefully that will help some people
out there and feel free to redirect
however you like but one of the most
popular highlights from from your book
the 15 commitments of conscious
leadership is this is looking at Kindle
highlights is quote self blame as
equally as toxic is blaming others or
circumstances and it is not taking
responsibility okay I want to just put
up a bookmark in that then one of our
other mutual friends
really highlighted how he loves your
perspective and thinking on personal
accountability so this is what he said
one of the beautiful ways
Jim helps people in relationships is
really helping them understand their own
accountability and role in dynamics they
may feel are being caused by the other
maybe explore his views on personal
accountability I have witnessed this in
you over and over and over and over
again you're acutely aware of how you
contribute to some of your own suffering
certain types of situations etc this
what I think struggle with is
distinguishing and enacting for myself
the personal accountability without it
turning into self blame mmm how would
you how would you speak to that because
on at face value it's it makes sense to
me like self blame just that word is so
loaded as equally as toxic as blaming
others or circumstances and it is not
taking responsibility so how do you
distinguish between those yeah I love
that question
so you know when you're working in
relationship people get pretty quickly
that blaming others you know causes all
kinds of drama and so that pretty
quickly they can say wow I should I
should begin to lessen the amount of
blame but then what they do is they
still think the situation is a problem
whether it's in a parenting thing or in
a relationship a marriage or an at work
they still think the situation is a
problem and if I'm not gonna blame you
for screwing it up then Who am I gonna
blame well one big option is to blame
oneself it's just natural and normal
somebody screwed it up the options are
I'm gonna blame you I'm gonna blame me
or I'm gonna blame them you know the
system the ones who kind of screwed it
up for all of us but all three of those
are still keeping me in a contracted
consciousness where I'm committed and
this is a key phrase to being right
that somebody screwed it up and needs to
have done it differently and when I am
in that contracted consciousness of
believing somebody screwed it up I mean
you know just look at the world win
right now did that the Chinese screw it
up did our that our government screw it
up you know who they're that them they
screwed it up
and now is it's getting more localized
now we're looking at all the ways that
in smaller micro communities were
placing blame on each other and then we
go back to blaming ourselves I should
have washed my hands one more time I
should have you know self quarantine
sooner I should have stocked my pantry
earlier but you'll notice that blame is
always a limiting contracting
fault-finding energy and it's always
rooted in the need to be right so the
antidote to blame and this is a big
assumption you know this is a big deal
as long as I think something is
fundamentally screwed up my ego identity
is going to look for who to blame the
shift is what if what is occurring is
actually here for my and our learning so
before we go to the meta issue that's
confronting all of us right now you know
like if I'm working with a team and
let's say they're in drama around you
know some something went down on their
one of their lines and at first they're
contracted they're below the line and
they start finger pointing and blaming
will you screwed it up I told you before
that needed servicing or somebody else
says you screwed it up you know you
didn't allocate enough funds and then
they turn it towards themselves I
screwed it up
but that's all predicated on it's a bad
thing that the line went down and of
course in in a very practical way it is
I get that but that just puts us in a
low learning state in a high learning
State what if we shift to there's no
need to blame anybody or hold anybody
accountable so accountability to me is
actually the route is to take account
for what went wrong and I think it's
actually counterproductive I like
radical responsibility so instead of
blaming somebody for what went wrong
what about if we take responsibility for
what we can learn and what if this is a
possibility for us individually and in
relationship and in the collective to
learn so once I can postulate something
as a learning opportunity the need to
blame diminishes blame comes with
something as screwed up and fault needs
to be assigned radical responsibility
comes from there's a chance to learn so
how did we co-create this so we can get
our learnings so there's a world of
difference between those two approaches
to life one keeps us in a high learning
state and one puts us in a low learning
state whenever we're in blame and
fault-finding we're not going to learn
much when we're in radical
responsibility the possibility for
learning is exponential infinite
literally does that make sense Tim it
does would you mind giving an example
from your personal experience whether
it's in your life or with teams or
clients individually I don't mind at all
so let me think of a situation going on
in my life so I can just reveal it to
you um yeah so a typical thing would be
I look at what I'm currently complaining
about that'd be a place that I'd start I
just look at what am I currently
complaining about
and one of the things that pops up for
me right now is I'm complaining that all
of our kids are not together we're
dispersed a couple of kids are in Europe
and then kids are in Chicago and kids
are in Michigan and it can look like a
problem it can look like a problem to be
fixed especially when I kind of take on
my father hand the energy you know now I
all the chickens back in the roost and
get them under my protective cover and
when I get there then I can start to
look for who to blame that the
circumstance is the way that it is and I
can start to identify all kinds of
people and circumstances and conditions
that I could start to blame some of them
are quite obvious I could blame the the
current virus I could blame the you know
sheltering in place I could blame the
limited space that we have up here I
could just start blaming things and then
that's gonna put me in a low learning
state if instead I say wow we're all not
together right now what could we learn
from that and get genuinely curious how
have we created ourselves not together
how could not being together before us
what could we learn from not being
together what possibilities arise from
not being physically together that
wouldn't be possible if we were
physically together so now I've moved
from needing to blame people
circumstances or conditions to getting
curious about what I can learn from the
situation being just the way it is I've
changed my entire relationship to the
content does that make sense can give a
practical business illustration one of
our coaches was working with a team and
they're a manufacturer they produce
stuff and they were having very very
difficult time filling one shift
and as it would be typical in a
situation like this it's a problem we
need to fill the shift we need to
populate it with better workers so when
they first go in
they're basically blaming people
circumstances or conditions that's what
we're gonna blame they decided the shift
and say how could we each take
responsibility for how we have created
ourselves under-resourced now that's a
radical question how have we created
ourselves under resource so we can learn
from it not so we can blame ourselves
and they spent several hours literally
brainstorming all the ways that they had
created themselves under-resourced and
from that place of above-the-line being
with the content from curiosity and from
responsibility instead of blame they
started to source all kinds of
innovative ways to solve the short flow
of human resource and literally changed
and solved it because they got done
blaming complaining bitching moaning and
took responsibility because they were
willing to see it as a learning
opportunity the language strikes me is
so important it has a reflection of
thinking and how thinking can inform
language but language can also inform
thinking and therefore inform that I
can't recall what you labeled it but
these sort of the like linguistic
emotional loop the how can we take
responsibility for co-creating X so that
we can learn not blame ourselves or
anyone else something along those lines
just the the importance of the actual
framing through a language seems really
significant yes let's if you're open to
it hop - these are all related of course
but us first a story from my experience
and I want to unpack some of that so you
and I first really connected this past
summer when I was working on a book
about saying no and I which I ended up
writing 200 pages of and the great irony
of the the notebook is that I in the
process of finding all these tools for
parsing what to say yes and no to
decided to say no to the book and
ultimately return the advance cancel the
book contract now that was that was in
just as you've jokingly said to me that
I've ruined her life because I've
introduced today being safe I'm gonna
jokingly say that you ruined my life
because you gave me all these great
tools that ultimately led me to
canceling the notebook which I will
share content of at some point but there
are a few pieces that jumped out at me
and I think that they are worth at least
explaining on a macro level so that
people don't think in case there are
people who are mistaking what we've
talked about for the last five or 10
minutes not saying that you don't give
straight talk that it's not important to
have straight talk because the context
in which we ended up really the speaking
was how do you have honest in some cases
blunt in some cases difficult to
conversations how do you create and
respect and protect boundaries right
which really can entail some for most
people uncomfortable conversations and
so I want to shift gears to talk about
that and a number of concepts and tools
hopped out in our conversations that I
found really useful and here's one that
I'd love to hear you elaborate on
because it seems to also strike a chord
with a lot of your clients and I'm gonna
paraphrase here and then I want you to
take it and run with it and correct me
if I'm screwing anything up here we go
all right this this was gonna be in a
chapter called the has TK Commandments
which just means to come in writings you
can search for stuff you need to fill in
later so it's gonna be like the 14
commandments of saying no something like
that this was one of the commandments
you're nearly always choosing one or two
paths so make it conscious the first
path is obligation which leads to
resentment which leads to entitlement or
you are choosing to freedom which leads
to appreciation which leads to
generosity and this sounds very kind of
highfalutin high concept but could you
kind of help land the plane and explain
what this means yes and how about if I
do it
in the context of my relationship with
Debbie so it's got a practical place
where we're playing alright alright
great so the first thing that Debbie and
I established early on in our
relationship was a set of commitments
that we wanted to engage each other in
our relationship with these commitments
become these 15 commitments most of
which we got from Gaye and Katy and then
a bunch of other people that we've
referenced so early on one of the
commitments we did is we said the big
commitment was we commit to being close
and to removing all barriers to
closeness that was a big cornerstone
commitment and then the other commitment
the other commitment that was germane to
this is we commit to reveal and not
conceal as a means to creating intimacy
not just physical intimacy and I like
intimacy if you hyphenated into me see
so we said okay we want to have a
relationship where we remove barriers to
closeness and from years of working with
couples and our own experience one of
the barriers to closeness is withholding
and withdrawing and then projecting our
stuff onto people so we instead we're
going to reveal that was the big
commitment in you and I've talked
anytime you commit to have an authentic
real transparent relationship you are
committing to messiness now in our
experience the messiness is worth it but
it does lead to messiness now one of the
things we decided was that we weren't
going to have a codependent relationship
and we were going to use candor
revealing ourselves authentically to
have a co committed versus codependent
relationship could unifying codependent
yeah yeah yeah yeah well let me just
define it the way I want to give a
particular definition to it based on
what youyou have teed up so a
codependent
elation ship is I'm going to take
responsibility for your happiness and
you're going to take responsibility for
my happiness and one of them and I'm not
going to take responsibility for my
happiness you're not going to take it
for yours we're gonna take it for each
other so now I'm gonna start to control
your happiness I'm gonna feel
responsible for it
and there are countless ways that I'm
going to try to control your happiness
minimize your unhappiness maximize your
happiness one of the ways is I'm not
gonna say what I really want and I'm not
gonna say what I don't want I'm not
gonna have a clear no and I'm not gonna
have a clear yes because if I'm honest
about my knowing yes there is a
possibility you will be upset and my job
in a codependent relationship is to keep
you from being upset by the way at the
bottom of that is I'm keeping you from
being upset because I'm gonna get upset
if you get upset with me
and that's the codependent in
measurement in a committed relationship
this is a radical way to live in my
experience but profoundly meaningful I
commit to be responsible for my own
happiness and well-being and Debbie
commits to be responsible for her own
happiness and well-being now what that
leads to is a commitment to be honest
and real about what we want and don't
want so you brought it up to him but in
a codependent relationship the pattern
is that people do things from obligation
should have to duty so I let's say I
stay home and I watch the kids out of
obligation not from freedom and then
after I've watched the kids for a while
while you're staying for late meetings
or traveling or whatever now I feel
resentful so I didn't have a whole body
yes - watching the kids I did it out of
obligation did feel like you were free
to choose
that's exactly right because we weren't
committed to having a real relationship
I was codependent and thought if I
refuse you're gonna get upset and you're
working so damn hard and you're taking
that extra trip and so I'm gonna live
from hood but then that subtle toxic
hardening of my heart is gonna occur I'm
gonna get food resentful a little pissed
off then that's gonna lead to
entitlement which is gonna look like
this you're gonna show up at home and
I'm gonna go listen here's what here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go out with
my buddies on Friday night and we're
gonna party down and party hard under me
subtext mean I don't really give a damn
what you think because I'm entitled to
that because I watch the kids so
obligation leads to resentment leads to
entitlement and that turns into a
vicious cycle in a codependent
relationship in a committed relationship
I say to Debbie listen I don't ever want
you in our relationship to do anything
from my obligation I don't first and
foremost I want you to tell me what you
genuinely want I want to know you and we
say all the time you're not responsible
for my happiness if you tell me what you
genuinely want and i unhappy myself to
your point funny languaging there he
doesn't make me unhappy i unhappy myself
that's my responsibility and i'll be
responsible for that what I want you to
do is tell me what you really want what
you have a yes to and what you have a no
- and when she makes that decision from
freedom let's say she really believes me
and she drops into herself and she feels
free to say what it is she wants that's
gonna lead so freedom instead of
obligation
it's gonna lead instead to resentment
it's gonna lead to appreciation she's
gonna have a natural upwelling inside of
herself appreciating herself and
appreciating me in our relationship
because she feels free to express
herself and that freedom is going to
lead to generosity instead of
entitlement which is gonna look like
generosity of spirit because she's
operating that way it's gonna be
generosity of spirit towards me and
towards our relationship so I'm
deconstructing from you've got to first
start with what are we commit to this is
what you and I talked about Tim when we
were talking about this if all of a
sudden most of a person's relationships
are built on obligation if you all of a
sudden say well I'm just gonna lead from
freedom and decide what I have a yes to
and what I have a no - that's gonna
probably cause a shitshow in your
relationship relationships because you
haven't faced an address that underneath
is this codependent enmeshment and until
that gets addressed trying to say we're
gonna live from clear yeses and clear
nose and from freedom and personal
responsibility for our happiness is not
the right conversation you've got to go
back to the core of what the
relationship is built on and every what
we call a commitment conversation like I
said when dev and I started we said
we're gonna be close which I don't
recommend that for all couples by the
way a lot of couples don't want to be
close there they have a transactional
relationship designed to allow them to
get where they're going in the world
they don't want closeness they want high
functionality at a Productivity level
but in our case we wanted closeness so
we said we're gonna be close and we're
gonna remove all barriers to closest
then we just started looking at what
causes us to not be close well one of
them was starting to live from
obligation instead of freedom taking
responsibility for the other person's
happiness rather than taking
responsibility for our own happiness and
we just started identif
I all the blockages to closeness again
largely influenced and coached by gang
Katy Hendricks and others so I'll pause
there does that make sense it does make
sense it definitely makes sense and I
want to just highlight where the rubber
meets the road both of our mutual
friends and you probably have more
actually we have more than two but the
the two that I keep referencing both
asked they sent maybe five or six
bullets each and they both asked me to
discuss your marriage with Debbie
because they they both said remarkable
marriage incredible marriage what does
he think are the cores of healthy
dynamic passionate relationships you can
guess who phrased it that way we won't
name him and then he has an amazing
marriage would be interested to have him
riff on what makes a good part in a
relationship so on and so forth so you
you actually have over a long period of
time put these practices into into
action so I just want to highlight that
for people also this isn't this isn't an
academic discussion and I don't know if
this will be totally related well
actually I'll make one comment and then
I'll follow up with my question the
comment is that this obligation and this
is just from our prior notes from phone
calls over the summer but this
obligation which leads to murders
resentment which we used to entitlement
could take a lot of forms right and one
example you gave me at one point I
believe was an employee I've been doing
all this for you write something from
obligations so you owe me I'm entitled
to get something in return for all that
I've done for you I had to work overtime
for instance therefore I'm entitled to
steal pens or whatever it might be right
it starts off small and generally
doesn't get smaller over time so the and
a lot of this and then I want to
fact-check me if I'm wrong on this but
much of our conversations including what
you just described came down to being
willing to have very candid and what
many people would consider uncomfortable
conversations and I think that that is
never more important than right now
where a lot of people are feeling fear
you have many people who are spun up um
personally not just from the current
circumstances but from their their life
and childhood experiences which are now
knocking on the door again to say hello
in in a very loud volume so the ability
in close quarters during say shelter at
home mandates strikes me as is really
important it's been very important for
me and my partner at least what what are
some of the what are some of the candid
or uncomfortable conversations that are
the most important to have hmm if any
come to mind aside from what we've been
discussing yeah yeah you know just quick
aside you know shelter at home if you're
sheltering at home with somebody you
don't like somebody that you've been
able to avoid difficult conversations
with because you've both been you know
consumed in the busyness of life that in
and of itself can be incredibly
stressful all of a sudden you're needing
to face feel and deal with stuff that
you haven't dealt with for months or
years so this one of the opportunities
that's coming up for many of us is can I
face stuff in my primary relationships
that I haven't faced another one that's
coming up is can I face the terror of
being alone and confined which you know
linguist Blaise Pascal who said
basically all the problems of humanity
come from man's inability to sit quietly
alone that's another thing that's coming
up here so as you look at your you know
close relationships whether it be with
your parents or with your siblings or
children this idea of are we willing to
be candid now I want to say something
here Tim because people misunderstand
this they think that if I'm below the
line if we keep using that language then
people will say I don't have a problem
being candid God you ask anybody in my
world they'll tell you I'm candid I tell
it like it is but what they're really
saying is they're kind of living a
scorched-earth policy where they tell
the truth all the time but they're rigid
and right
just about being attached to their truth
so we don't call that candor what we
call candor begins with the ability to
differentiate facts from stories facts
or data facts are what is totally
unarguable facts are that which all
reasonable people would agree to facts
the facts of life stories are judgments
opinions beliefs interpretations that we
make up about the facts so for example
where that typical thing would be I walk
in Alice Debbie standing there fact a
video camera would record that the
corners of her mouth are turned down
slightly in what one could call a frown
that's a fact
video camera would record it now my mind
starts making up stories
Debbie's upset with me I did something
wrong she's going to criticize me and
now I start reacting to the stories
defending justifying explaining reacting
to the stories even though the stories
are all made up in my mind
so candor practicing conscious candor
first you differentiate fact from story
and then you reveal your stories holding
them lightly so from below the line I
want to be right about my stories and
prove that I'm right because my ego
identification believes it can only
survive if it's right so what that would
look like is
you know from below line I'd say what
are you upset about I I'm only ten
minutes late and I I know I forgot the
milk but Gav's very busy so now I'm
revealing my story that she's upset in a
reactive mode ality while holding
tightly to my story that a she is upset
at me and B she shouldn't be that
truth-telling that's not what we're
talking about at all candor I
differentiate that from story and here's
what this might look like I walk in the
house and let's say I'm above the line
and present which I might not be I might
say something like this hey when I look
over it looks like you're upset I'm
making up the story that you're upset
and rather than get all scared and
reactive to that first thing I do is
just want to tell you I'm making up that
story and I want to check it out with
you are you upset and by the way when I
make up the story that you're upset I
notice I get defensive furthermore
probably what I really get is scared cuz
I don't want you to be pissed off at me
but I'm gonna reveal myself to you
Debbie not from being right this act of
candor is an act of incredible
vulnerability I'm gonna let you know me
when I said all the time I'm gonna let
you know what's going on on planet and
Jim my thoughts beliefs interpretations
wants desires so you can know me not so
that I can prove I'm right and by the
way this kind of candor goes
hand-in-hand with conscious listening
people always wanna say I want a more
candid relationship with my partner I
say great before you start revealing
start listening start becoming a person
to whom others will reveal themselves
candidly because you see them and you
hear them and you get them then as they
feel safe to reveal themselves you'll
find that the relationship becomes more
safe for you to reveal yourself
so candor and conscious listening go
hand and glove but again it's a cold
commitment right Debbie and I said we
want to remove all barriers to closeness
one of the barriers to closeness is not
revealing ourselves to each other it's
so easy to hide out for fear of being
rejected for fear of being criticized
the risk and Deb and I have been
practicing candor for decades Tim and
there's almost always some edge of
candor where I could reveal a thought or
I could reveal a judgment in our case
specifically about our children because
it's our second relationship debbie has
four boys I have two girls well
sometimes I have judgments about her
boys it's always risky to say to her hey
I just want to tell you I got a
judgement coming up in me about
so-and-so because she cares about her
boys and she's irrationally involved and
just like I am with my girls
every time I practices vulnerability in
candor in my intimate relationship
there's a modicum of fear that comes up
because who knows how she's gonna react
we do have decades now practicing so
pretty good chance that we'll work it
through so that's what candor is
differentiate fact from story hold your
story lightly revealed to the other for
the sake of being known not for proving
you're right and practice deeply
listening so the other person trusts you
enough to reveal themselves as a short
primer on candor I'll pause there I want
to give an example of how my girlfriend
principally she actually started she
introduced this uh-huh and then I
quickly embraced it when I realized how
effective it was for diffusing tension
and it's exactly what you're describing
and that is the phrasing of I'm making
up the story dot dot right and the way
that she phrased it was simply the story
I'm making up in my head is dot dot dot
and I have a long history of sure how to
put this in a way that doesn't make me
look like a [ __ ] but fighting I
guess is a way to put it yeah I just I I
was I enjoyed being right and maybe
disliked being wrong was a better way to
put it and if I felt attacked
I would kind of respond in kind
right and actually not in kind of sort
of the Bruce Lee if you graze my skin I
pound your flesh if you pound my flesh I
break your bones necessary escalation
but I historically ran with very little
slack in the system right I was always
redlining so the the least bit of
provocation would would lead to this
really outsized response and as soon as
she presented something as the story I'm
making up in my head is it basically
disarmed me completely in the most
positive way imaginable and that has
just been a huge game-changer for us and
we've been in isolation for weeks we
were early adopters and it was very
difficult in the beginning especially
because our friends were whether they
said it or not and some of them
certainly did thought we were crazy
thought we were insane people and I I
credit my girlfriend and tools like this
for allowing us to so far at least to
cohabitate surprisingly well and the the
crux distinction is the one that you
mentioned and that is separating facts
from story like if it cannot be recorded
by a video camera or a voice memo it's
probably not a fact it's probably a
story and at least pausing even if you
feel like it's fact different to see if
you can frame it as a story has just
been so powerful I want to mention that
because these these really do have
tremendous applications so I just wanted
to mention that I don't know if that
brings up anything for you or anything -
tad but but certainly I have yeah more
questions I that the line from Rumi came
to me where he says there's a field
beyond right and wrong I will meet you
there and it sounds like your girlfriend
is committed to something behind right
and wrong by the way that doesn't mean
that the category is right and wrong or
useless we should throw them out become
absolute relativists doesn't mean that
at all it means that there is a place
called right and there is and we need to
be their times and have that
conversation but there's a field beyond
that and when she says to you Tim I'm
making up the story in my mind that
she's saying to you I'm interested in
something other than needing to be right
I'm interested in being known and
knowing you I've said there's so many
couples over the years you're more
interested in being right than you are
to being close I've said the team's
executive teams you're more interested
in being right about your position than
you are in being successful as a team
the addiction to being right which is
the little ego identities it it doesn't
believe it can survive if it's not right
and when these little ego identities
like yours and mine get locked into
drama based conflictual relationships
all that matters is the survival of the
ego that's it that's all that matters
and the key to my ego surviving is I
can't be wrong I like the way you said
that I can't be wrong maybe I need to be
right but for God's sake I can't be
wrong and then if you're gonna be there
and I'm gonna be there good luck for
innovation improvisation creativity let
alone intimacy and closeness so we're
exploring right now in this conversation
a different way to do that and it really
is predicated on I'm more interested in
something other than just being right
and that's a game changer and and I
would I would I would say and you're
you've you're an old hand at this and
I'm new to discussing the concepts so
please feel free to improve or
completely refute whatever I say but it
also strikes me that if you are unable
or unwilling to try to separate
the facts from your stories and present
your stories in a candid early and
non-threatening way so you don't wait
until things are at the boiling point
that you will suffer from you will
suffer multifold from the three primary
emotions that we discussed earlier sad
angry scared right I mean I've noticed
such a change in my life certainly as it
relates to those three things since
adopting the sort of early early candid
intervention with the framing of my own
stories yeah and not to say that I'm not
struggling now I mean it's it's I'm
having I've had a very tough time in the
last few weeks and that actually leads
me to what I wanted to ask you about
next and that is the mental model of
human development of quote to me by me
through me as me and I don't know if I
am labeling that correctly but could you
elaborate on what that means yeah sure
so this model I first heard from Michael
Beckwith we've taken it and change it so
he he might not recognize it that much
but first time I heard this model it
made such sense to me and he he
describes it as four states of
consciousness not stages they're not
developmental you don't proceed from one
to the other like you would from you
know childhood to adolescence to
adulthood these are States so we go in
and out of them more like the dream
state the awake State and the dreamless
State and they they map pretty well so
we use them as this context for contexts
for contexts that answer how are we
being with the content of life and the
content can be whatever it is okay
so the first context is we're being with
life from to me real simple it just
means we're at the effect of life we are
at the effect of people circumstances
and conditions it's happening to me so
we're in victimhood
or victim consciousness and I was pause
here and say in parentheses there are
true victims in the world let's just
stipulate to that but that's different
than victim consciousness so sometimes
I'll talk about you know in my family of
origin you know my mom was an alcoholic
my dad sexually abused my sister my
brother was a rageaholic you know kind
of like most of this kind of a batshit
crazy environment well you know as a
little boy there's a way in which I
truly was at the infect of the
environment you could say I was a victim
in the experience that's true let's just
say that's true okay but now if I'm 65
66 years old and I'm still blaming my
parents for my current state of being
now I'm in to me in victim consciousness
so to me is it's happening to me
real simple and you know quite frankly
this is where most people live most of
the time if you just turn on the news
doesn't matter what news you turn on any
news you're gonna hear people speaking
from to me they're doing it to me it's
happening to me so that's to me then the
next state of consciousness is by me
this is radically different if the first
one is victimhood
this is creatorship this is a state of
empowerment this is a place where I'm no
longer seeing myself as at the effect of
now I'm seeing myself as responsible for
and creator of my experience now that's
really important I'm the creator of my
experience so the virus is a real thing
happening out there that is a fact you
you more than any could could give us a
list of all the facts but my
relationship to the virus for example am
i living paralyzed in
fear am i living in denial am i my
relationship to it is my responsibility
so I can either be at the effect of the
current circumstances where most of us
live or I can say wait a minute
I'm gonna take responsibility for how
I'm going to be with this and that goes
from a meta pandemic all the way down to
how I'm going to be with the weather I
could be at the effect of the weather or
I could say the weather is what it is
I'm up here in northern Michigan oh no
it's 27 degrees out and I could say wow
the weather is what it is and I can
choose to be the creator of my
experience with the weather so the
movement from to me to buy me the
Gateway is learning to take
responsibility then the third state of
consciousness is through me and this is
a I think a tremendously empowering way
to live most people spend most of their
time in to me then they start to become
skilled at living life and they start to
feel you know authorship and they start
to stand in being the creator of their
experience and then it's not uncommon
for them to say is there something else
going on in the world other than me and
my Purpose Driven Life my authorship of
what I want in life is there anything
else going on and this leads to this
question of is there anything else going
on besides me now this starts to move us
into the realm of things like possibly
spirituality but it doesn't have to be
spiritual a lot of people have a
tremendous aversion to that word it
could just be is life wanting to do
something so when I get over here I
start to say what does life want to do
through me and to many people that's an
absurd question so I just say great
don't ask that question but there are
countless people for whom that
an interesting question well you know
when you and I can connected today
before we started and we talked about
what we wanted and I think I said
something like I just want to be
surrendered to what wants to come
through us today I'm not I'm certainly
not a victim at the effect of what's
happening here even when we had
technical difficulties they were just
occuring we could learn I could go into
creator and say well actually I have a
lot of things that I want to create with
you Tim and be purposeful intentional
wonderful way to live life
directive on point but I actually like
to play in the space of I don't know man
how about if we both just get into our
creative energy follow impulse and be in
kind of a dynamic dance with what shows
up and in my experience that through me
experience is unbelievably fun a
synchronistic you know um we have
friends who are you know world-class
athletes and some of them who've you
know performed in many many arenas and
oftentimes like if I'm talking to a snow
skier or a surfer they really relate to
this you know like when somebody I don't
surf but it they I my surfing friends
tell me this is true when you first get
on a board you are very much in to me
you are at the effect of the board
you're at the effect of balance you're
at the effect of the wind you're at the
effect of the waves right your your
whole body is tense your rigid your
efforting like crazy to me is efforting
like crazy and when you fall off you
[ __ ] moan and complain the board's too
long the board's too heavy why did that
win why did my teacher put me out it
that's to me then somebody says hey you
know there are actually some principles
that govern surfing and if you learn
those principles and start taking
responsibility for applying those
principles you're gonna start to see
that you can become the creator of your
own experience and then you can spend
weeks months years mastering the bymy
state of surfing but every person who's
passionate about surfing that I've ever
talked to said you know they were
getting really skilled they were they
could really master the principles and
then one day they
got about all the principles it was just
them their board and the water and they
had an experience and people however
they say this that surfing was happening
through me or musicians say all of a
sudden music was coming through me or or
you know people who innovate they say
that idea I just kind of let go and
something came through me so everybody's
got a feel for this sometime you know
it's kind of what flow state is like you
know I never forget being in Chicago
Michael Jordan makes seven threes in a
row or whatever runs down the court kind
of throws up his hands looks at the
crowd looks at the announcers like even
I'd argue the greatest basketball player
ever played arguable but my story this
is happening through me this is wild yet
I'm just showing up so we've all had
that experience and to me that's when
leaders start dancing there
it's incredible what comes forward into
the world and then the fourth state is
as me it's non duality its oneness it's
it's the blurring of a personal self
even though there is a personal self
it's being fully human but being in the
dance of beingness so now we move over
into all the traditions whether it's
Buddhism or Hinduism or Islam or
Christianity or non-religious
spirituality they all have a version of
this idea of becoming one and you know
now we could go back over into your
world I'm a baby in this world of
medicine journeys but you know I've only
done for us I talked to you once before
but and I got involved because I many
reasons but one of the things I had
happened very quickly was the
dissolution of a separate self and and
this experience of oh my god small G
right so there's many things that those
medicine
are bringing to the world you beam you
know an expert a proponent of this but
just as a newbie that's like an instant
portal through to as me the good and the
bad that terror and the bliss the you
know the whole deal
so those are the four states to me by me
through me as me and in my experience we
go in and out of them all the time so
when you and I had technical
difficulties partway through our call
and you couldn't hear me
I immediately contracted into into to me
ah yet what did i do i took my earphones
on I put it back in I'm not very
technically savvy I [ __ ] this up oh
god what am i doing I can hear you
saying Jim I'm talking but I can't hear
him go God what do i do what do i do to
me at the effect of me and the
technology then I go wait a minute take
a breath I take a breath and I go this
is okay what can I learn from here what
could i play with what could I do so
just a breath shift into by me access
iqe ubq and then you and I start dancing
we call though we could do this we could
shift over to this platform we don't
need to be in reactivity we don't need
to be contracted in fear to do me by me
through me as be dancing all the time so
that's a model that I love love love it
seems to map really well to all of life
whatever the content is whether it's the
weather or the virus or the technology
breaking down when you and I were
talking I can always ask myself where am
I a Mayan to me by me through mirror
asked me and my context is under my
control the content never is yeah thank
you for explaining that there's a lot to
unpack we could we could unpack each
Alonso's for for many hours but one of
our mutual friends is a fan of what most
people would consider bad weather and he
also trained train sounds too much like
a dog in a in a kennel but he sort of
has cultivated this this belief and his
kids and I can't recall the proper
attribution of this quote but there's
there
no such thing as bad weather just
inappropriate clothing and to really
celebrate what most people would
complain about and just as a quick aside
I was going for a a hike with my
girlfriend of my dog recently just a
very very basic neighborhood hike
nothing nothing to alpine and we got
caught in this torrential downpour
I mean chill downpour and perhaps a
month ago or two months ago that that
would have bothered me on some level and
it ended up just being this we reframed
it really quickly and having been holed
up at home so much in the last few weeks
it was just the greatest gift we could
have imagined we we had hoods we took
down our hoods just so we got pour it on
and as we're walking home on the street
we're waving to these cars with these
huge shit-eating grin on her face it's
it's it's really easy and I succumb to
this all the time to fall into a to me
though this is happening to me as
opposed to by me or for me right in this
case it was yeah for me like no this is
something that's happening for me not to
me
and it really changes things and I would
love you you volunteered and I
appreciate you volunteering some
background in terms of your childhood
and suffice to say a lot of people are
suffering right now feeling suffering
right whether and legitimately so many
people are facing extremely difficult
circumstances but if if we're if we take
just as a frame for discussion the the
old military expression your pain is
inevitable suffering is optional in the
sense that you you can reframe these
things you will have twists of fortune
that cause you great difficulty I would
love to visit perhaps at a difficult
time in in your life and I've heard you
describe this and I won't say much more
but as the descent to the ashes
could you talk about where that comes
from
and your own descent to the ashes and
how you got through that hmm yeah
appellee um so if I go back to you know
I've always had this ache in my chest
and I've always thought for relationship
the first place I looked was to
Christianity because I heard Jesus
whatever people think of Jesus make this
ridiculous claim that you could have
peace that passes understanding and then
the version of Christianity that I got
involved in had as simple now I would
say greatly oversimplified the process
by which you could do that so for the
first you know from the time I was
fifteen until I was 40 my practice was
around Christianity that's where my
meditation started and my practice
became my career my advanced degrees in
theology and then I became a minister
and fast forward all the way to 43 years
old a minister of the largest church in
the United States so you know talking to
thousands of people a week in this
complex system of a church so now I'm
right smack dab in the midst of midlife
and I realize that my life is not
working now specifically the faith that
I had been devoted to I wasn't casual
about it wasn't producing the results
that it looked like it should produce
love joy peace instead I was getting
further away from the things that I was
seeking so I quit you know it you know
in that world kind of near the pinnacle
of my career path if you will I climb
the ladder right literally and found the
ladder leaning against the wrong wall so
I quit and I started this journey I
started this journey to find same thing
relief peace and what a relationships
like and that journey took me to some of
these teachers that were talking about
and then like I said once I found these
teachers I came back and brought it to
people I become a private practice
counselor at that point
another friend of mine and I started
men's groups largely just doing I've
just given to others what I need it for
myself men in midlife figuring out what
the hell does it mean to be a fully
alive human and so we started doing you
know all the stuff that men would do you
know you would go into the woods and we
would you know beat drums and do all
that stuff the men's movement in the 70s
and 80s which I think there was a lot of
beauty to that it paralleled the women's
movement and it got messy and this
church that I had been a part of which
gives largest church in the United
States was still selling tapes that I'd
get talks I'd given all over the world
and they got winded out in the woods you
know we'd have men move their anger so
they'd yell [ __ ] hell damn [ __ ] ate
you know beat a bag and we'd all talk
about the shame that we carry in our
body things that were done to our buddy
you know radical cutting-edge stuff
which I think was incredibly
transformational for people the church
got wind of this and they said you can't
do that and I hadn't gone there for
several years but this was kind of one
path then on another path I was in this
relationship with my first wife that I
had managed to royally screw up we both
did but I take my hundred percent
responsibility for creating a really
marginal relationship and creating lots
of suffering for me and for her well one
of the decisions I made was at that
point I decided that I was going to
enter into a relationship with Debbie my
current wife while I was still in my
marriage okay that was a big decision at
that point I'd you know only had sex
with one person I thought and I thought
the moment I get into relationship with
Debbie my life as I know it is over
because my life had been about being a
person of integrity and a good person
and stuff like that and this gets to the
descent of the ashes I had built a life
largely constructed out of identities or
personas that wasn't aligned with my
true self now since I've walked a lot of
people through this and I said you don't
have to burn the house
down you can course correct and you can
do it gently but I burnt the house down
so Debbie and I were in relationship we
stopped being in relationship I told my
entire world that I'd had a relationship
with Debbie including my wife and my
kids and then a few months later decided
to end my marriage so here's what the
Descent that the ashes look like I moved
out of my house and out a lot of money
moved into my office I was living in my
office counseling people during the day
and then at the same time this church
decided to publicly disavow so it ends
the culmination of this descent of the
ashes is a front-page article in the
Chicago papers say in the name of the
church disavows former minister and it
talks about what we were doing with
these guys and the transformation that
was occurring and then the fact that I
had had a relationship with Debbie while
Mary it became public to everybody
so here I am 43 years old but been you
know a year prior to that I was a person
with a phenomenal reputation and you
know some amount of clout in the world
and now I'm living in my office with
nothing
most of the men who had been working
with us left for legitimate reason
because I'd been out of integrity with
them so now my life has just descended
down to nothing and it was from there
that I started to put a new life back
together bit by bit by bit with a
certain set of gating criteria like is
this authentic that's when I decided I
would never keep another secret as long
as I lived now I differentiate there's
private stuff but I've kept lots of
Secrets as a minister in order to be
good and fit in
I didn't tell all the truth about who I
was and so I decided I wouldn't to keep
any secrets I have private stuff in my
life but nothing that shame based so I
say to people have time you can take
this and put on the front of the New
York Times it's just my story of the
story that bears my name so that was the
descent to the ashes and I say that the
views to the people that you know are
part of your I'm gonna tribe is a lot of
people get to a point in their life
where they go this isn't working
like this marriage doesn't work you know
this family isn't working or this career
isn't working or this identity isn't
working now what do I do and in my
experience a lot of what I want to offer
to the world is there ways that we can
reform that back to something that is
more congruent and authentic liberating
and powerful without needing to blow up
our lives or blow up you know I talk to
people all the time there are good
divorces and bad divorces bad divorces
are sourcing blame and criticism
there's innocent collateral damage and
basically third parties get all your
money in good ending of relationship
there's not a lot of blame and criticism
there's responsibility where I get my
learnings because I take responsibility
I'm not a viscera ting my partner
consciously or unconsciously in front of
my children so the collateral damage
lessens and we don't try to beat the
[ __ ] out of each other through the court
systems therefore dissipating all our
money and energy so there's ways to
navigate these things and I'm grateful
you know I kind of like I said I blew my
life up I don't recommend that there are
a lot of people who still need to blow
their life up and then how to put back
together a life that aligns with the
truth of who we are which is a big idea
of what I'm up to in my life so I don't
know whether that's exactly what you
were looking for but that's a little bit
about what I mean by descent to the
ashes oh it is it definitely is and and
I want to ask if you follow up questions
so that the first is more of a supposed
academic note of interest and that is
that the descent to the ashes that
phrase is from the hero's journey is it
not yes it is yep self Joseph Campbell
for those yeah who are interested in
exploring that and that implies the
reason I bring that up that this is a
common chapter in life for many people
or a common experience the descent to
the ashes so much so that it's in the
hero's journey the story of the hero the
hero of a Thousand Faces and I would be
curious to know when you are talking
someone through their own descent to the
ashes whether they've blown their life
up or not maybe they've tempted to
course-correct but they feel as though
they are they are currently in the
descent to the ashes what are questions
that you encourage them to ask or what
do you suggest that they do mm-hmm and I
know it's very context dependent there
can here a million different iterations
but are there any any examples you could
give or samples yeah okay so there's a
whole set of conversations I like that
let's just take a couple one of them is
in the process I like to ask people what
do you want and what do you really want
not as a casual question but as a
question for them to go sit in not
figure out so again getting Katy used to
teach us about wonder questions wonder
questions are questions that are so big
you live in the question figure it out
questions are things you can figure out
with the skill of your mind or by doing
some googling so one of the things I
like to do early on in the process is to
say to somebody I want you to go for a
walk I want you to go sit I want you to
just live in the question what do I want
that's the first one but the more
important one is what do I really want
if I were free to want what I want
parentheses most people aren't I say to
them all the time
your water got broken when you were a
little kid so we got to get your water
back online right very dr. Seuss
isn't it true now some people have a
really active water and they terrorize
their world with their narcissistic
entitlement I'm not talking about that
but a lot of people if we go back to
they took on a role as a little kid like
I took on the role in my family of being
the Savior the reliever of suffering the
all-white night because of the hit show
that was going on well I took that role
on and then I just developed a career
based on the role I never got to ask
what do I really want
so people aren't free to ask what they
really want because they took on a role
or they took on obligation or there's
living somebody else's dream so when you
get to this conversation one of the
great questions is what do you want what
do you really want another question I
ask people all the time and this is
another big question what are you
willing to put at risk for full
aliveness I love that question isn't it
that's a great question could I hear it
yeah please please say Marth
well first of all it doesn't mean that
you have to put it at risk I just say if
if all of a sudden you decided that
aliveness because usually when people
get to where I got to their aliveness
has been greatly stunted I wasn't alive
in my marriage I didn't know how to be I
wasn't alive in my career I wasn't alive
and there was Mata comes of a line as I
looked alive but I wasn't fully alive so
what I've experienced over the years is
and this is true today now I'm still in
the question what am I willing to put at
risk for my full aliveness so let's go
back to candor so we don't introduce a
whole lot of new threats in my
relationship with Debbie I am committed
to being fully alive and committed to
having a fully alive relationship what
I'm willing to put at risk for that is
temporary discomfort messiness I'm
willing to put my happiness and her
happiness at risk for the moment I'm
willing to endure what Scott Peck called
I love this the tunnel of chaos memory
his eye his model was great you go from
pseudo community what was the name again
Scott Peck Scott back yep that's what is
this the way of the Peaceful work now
which why am I missing yeah I remember
people of the live was one of his book
we can find it yeah he's got that
another one of these great models that I
stole you go from pseudo community which
all of us have we we tend to
towards pseudo community then we tell
the truth either intentionally
accidentally skillfully unskillful e and
then we go into the tunnel of chaos and
then if we value learning we come out on
the other side in authentic community
and in my experience in relationships
whether it's a high-performing team at
work or you know a group of teachers in
an educational institution or community
activists and the west side of Chicago
the tendency is to be in pseudo
community which is here what do you mean
by pseudo community will be an exam of
that what's know community is where
we're prioritizing niceness and civility
over authenticity got it we are we're
pretending rather than being real
because we know that if we got authentic
or we got real things would get messy
and we don't trust ourselves in each
other enough to go through the mess and
get to authentic community on the other
side by the way here's what's wild once
you get to authentic community it feels
so good
you start safeguarding it and start
drifting back towards pseudo community
because you stop telling the truth it
never stops never stops with me and
every doesn't stop with me and my kids
doesn't stop with me and our shared
mutual friends so a second question is
what are you willing to put at risk for
your phone ride are you willing to put
your financial security at risk for full
aliveness are you willing to put some
relationships at risk are you willing to
put your reputation at risk are you
willing what are you willing to put in
the corollary of course is what won't
you put at risk for full aliveness this
is such a good question typically people
who have kids will say I won't put my
kids well-being at risk for full
eliteness I love that answer first of
all I get it support it live it but I'm
drawn back to some of the great
understand people who understand
parenting who say the number one gift we
have to give to our children is our
aliveness so now you're in the parrot
of I'm gonna sub optimized my aliveness
so that I can create some sense of
safety and security for my kids again I
totally get it
but what my kids catch in the air or
through the water is that sub optimized
aliveness is the way to live life so
it's just a tension that I want to take
somebody through what are you gonna do
with that tension and these
conversations what do I want what do I
really want what am I willing to put at
risk for my full aliveness these occur
both in meaningful maximal ways when
we're at the precipice of the descent of
the ashes but these are conversations in
my experience that occur every day what
do I want what do I really want what am
I willing to put at risk for my full of
aliveness and then the third thing in
there many but the third thing we want
to do an integrity inventory because we
define integrity is just energy it's
just aliveness it's not moral or ethical
it's just a my whole from the word
integer a my whole and am i
energetically whole and alive and
integrity breeches are anything that
interrupts my aliveness my wholeness so
again I got from gay Hendricks the four
pillars of integrity from gay and Katy
and so whenever I'm walking people
through this I want to have them check
the four pillars and those are do they
have any unsaid so we've talked about
candor do they have any
uncaps do they have any agreements they
haven't kept because any place where
you've made an agreement and aren't
keeping it it's an integrity breach and
it's it's not a moral thing it's just
you're losing energy do they have any
unsaid zenny uncaps any unknown this is
any place where they're still blaming
somebody else rather than owning their
life and do they have any unfelt any
feelings they haven't felt so in my work
I had to go back and feel feelings about
my job
by the way once you commit to do this it
can be done quite rapidly and quite
efficiently there are technologies for
this that once I was willing to feel
things say things own things and agree
to things integrity came back online and
I had serious integrity breaches so
that's another big one what is your
current integrity inventory because if
you're gonna build the life that gives
you full aliveness it's going to be
rooted in integrity and we could have a
wonderful conversation around what all
that means but those would be three
things I look at with people when
they're exploring either many shifts at
the ED midlife or the big ones well you
know I feel like we could do an entire
separate podcast episode on this
integrity inventory which which if
you're if you're open to we can talk
about no pressure but that's that I
think could be a very fun and also
selfishly helpful practice for me Scott
Peck side note I was struggling to find
the other book title the road less
traveled is the other book yes yes yes
yes and so the integrity inventory and
which which you said I think this is
important because this word can be used
to mean so many things but the integrity
is equaling energetic wholeness right
yes identifying energy leaks or where
you are losing energy the unsaid the
unkept agreements the unknown things
where you're blaming other people on the
unfelt feelings I've that is that is
really tremendous I think I've mostly
focused on the unsaid z' and the unfelt
feelings but less so on the other two so
I think I've only covered half of my
bases we will come back at some point to
to that framework maybe not in this
conversation but I'd love to skip back
to something that you said and we don't
have to delve into this if you prefer
not to but many people right now are
feeling disrupted on
settled whether for instances some of my
relatives have been let go from service
jobs from working in restaurants and
other businesses or they have a physical
business they they are mechanics for
instance or any any number of other
things there are dozens of examples
probably hundreds of examples I could
give and in some cases they've been
forced into a position of questioning
what they can do or what they want to do
and then I think many people right now
also in a period of crisis are
reflecting on these things and asking
themselves some of these questions maybe
they are trying to figure them out and
not to sit with them and I'd like to
actually hear you describe what that
means but you mentioned very briefly
from 15 to 40 and then at 43 I quit I
feel like there's more to that story
it seems to me that that must have been
difficult could you speak to that point
in time because I think it by I think
it'll transfer to many people's
situations you have this identity that
is wrapped up in what you've been doing
for a very long time you have a belief
structure that at least at some point
was identified with this particular
faith this particular path you have some
level of being recognized by a community
as credible as competent in this path
how did you end up quitting was it was
it a flash moment of realization and
then very quick action was it agonizing
over it for months or years I mean what
did that what did that look like and how
did you finally decide to shift gears
and to walk and I just want to highlight
to people that this is not for me this
is not a question that is religious
specific or religion specific it's that
that is a huge that is a huge lane shift
so if you could speak to that if you're
willing to I would I would love to hear
more yeah sure
so the dissatisfaction that was growing
was growing over time as I think these
kinds of shifts it is really truly
sudden usually there are the beginnings
of it and there were the beginnings of
this so again if we go back to my big
idea I was driven by a desire for peace
and I was driven by a desire for
authentic relationship and as I
continued on both my professional
journey and my spiritual journey I
wasn't seeing more peace I was more
famous I was more successful I was more
impactful in many ways but on the inside
I wasn't getting what I wanted and I
didn't know how to have an authentic
relationship with my wife I just didn't
know I I was a complete goofball and
once I got inside now this is just about
me I'm not making a statement here about
Christianity but once I got onto the
inside of my experience of Christianity
I found that we got more interested in
being good than in being free and in
being big than in being loving now those
are all meaningful words to me so the
last chapter of our book is called the
change formula and it's what does it
take to produce lasting change again
this is not original to us I forget it
we got it from but we give credit there
and it's V times D plus FS greater than
our equal seat all it means is this in
order to produce change which is the C
something has to be greater than the
resistance to change which we all have
and the something that will produce
change by overcoming the resistance is V
times D vision times dissatisfaction in
other words you got a multiplier people
change either because they've got a big
huge vision that they cannot realize
from the current way they're living or
they've got pain and you
it's a multiplier effect so for me the
cumulative effect over years was that I
still had a vision for peace and
authentic relationship I still did and I
wasn't living it wasn't about my
circumstances it was about me and I had
tremendous dissatisfaction pain
depression oxd all kinds of stuff those
two came together to produce a
propulsion that was so meaningful
I couldn't keep going so I went to my
friend and the guy who actually was the
leader of the church and I said listen
it's not that I think these things that
I believed aren't true they just don't
work I came across David White's
beautiful poem called I think it's
called self portrait and the opening
line of the poem is for me this was very
important it doesn't interest me if
there is one god or many gods it doesn't
interest me if there's one god or many
gods I want to know if you can feel and
then he makes this list you know
heartbroke and chaos melt into life
well I'd spent my whole life arguing is
there one God or many gods and versions
of that argument and it didn't matter to
me now part of the melt like it I love
it that you said I quit there had to be
more of the story well if you
double-click on quit it included losing
30 pounds in you know a month incredible
shame like I had this huge message of a
I [ __ ] up I didn't get it right and I
had a relationship outside of my
marriage in you know for some people
that's not a big deal for me that was a
big deal that was like you know right up
there in the bit you know it's kind of
in the big 10 you know so the physical
dissolution a sense of shame and failure
looking at my
otters eyes who was going into high
school as a freshman in high school when
there's a front-page article that says
this big famous Church in the community
disavows her father I can eat I feel
tears in my eyes even now say that has
got 25 years 30 years ago it was a mess
Tim and often the descent to the ashes
can be but doesn't have to be I want to
say it again it doesn't have to be and
so this you know all this melting down
and literally I hadn't I had no money
and because I felt so badly about what I
done to my marriage I said to my wife
I'll make all the money I'll just take
care of you but I didn't know how to do
that to figure out how to turn being a
minister into a way to make money so I'd
innovate create you know and that became
the beginning of a coaching practice and
stuff like that all the while there were
these little we're up here in northern
Michigan like I said it's cold and
you're sick we're standing outside and
Debbie looked down the ground and there
was this little white flower coming
through a double of stew garden she's
got into her bliss space you know as as
the beginning of spring starts to come
through the ground all the while there
was the beginning if nothing else is I
didn't have to pretend anymore so many
of us you know destroy our aliveness
through pretending I wasn't gonna
pretend and then slowly but surely life
started to come back including
eventually getting back with Debbie and
creating this great relationship and I
got a great relationship with my kids
and I'm doing what I was put on the
planet to do and I'm still kind of a
monk you know I was joking with you like
I don't do social media and I live kind
of like a monk up here and I'm still
kind of that way but it's just much more
aliveness so yes there was more to just
to it than just I quit
and there usually is with a person
there's more to the story yeah thank you
so much for sharing that I'm very
grateful that you we're willing to share
that I think that's going to really
impact a lot of people who are listening
I was certainly listening very closely
and holy [ __ ] I mean that sounds
extremely difficult and painful and
terrifying and I can see where the the
blame in the self flagellation would
also be intense and we all [ __ ] up
alright we I mean we all welcome in
around ways and I appreciate you being
so transparent with describing it and
there's part of me that feels like this
is a great place to wrap up and then
there's part of me that feels like we
should probably have an off-ramp of a
few minutes from that but I do think
that that will speak to go to a lot of
people and what what else I've been
asking questions the the the entire
conversation are there any other topics
let's just say in the remaining five or
ten minutes or questions that you'd like
to explore does anything does anything
come to mind yeah two things come to
mind um I just want to say first of all
I'm grateful that the story that bears
my name this journey could be of service
maybe to you in this moment maybe to
some others I'm grateful for that you
know that's part of the it's part of the
beauty of Grace in a non religious term
just grace that what I once called a
cosmic [ __ ] and by the way I don't
only judge myself that way maybe I am
God in the picture so I had God the
cosmic [ __ ] up part of grace is that
those things can be made of service I
think that's beautiful I say that the
leaders all the time when in the privacy
of intimate conversations we're
revealing what's really true and to say
you know God what you're you know
wanting to hide and run from right now
we can be gentle with all that and take
all the time we need and the possibility
is that it could someday be of
tremendous service to you to your family
to the world that's kind of the way I
tend to see life one thing comes up for
me I mentioned it in passing
but I want to tie it back here I'd like
what Hale Dwoskin the teacher of the
Sedona Method another you can put that
in what you're showing notes whatever
you call those one of the things I got
from Hale was that our identities are
always seeking for things that and I
mentioned them approval control security
and oneness they're self-evident what I
was doing up until I was 43 years old is
I was largely outsourcing approval
control security and oneness so I would
feel approved of when I gave a talk to
you know thousands of people or large
crowds and afterwards everybody would
come up and say that was great that was
great that really helped me that was
meaningful and then one person would say
I disagree with that that wasn't your
best talk and because I was outsourcing
approval
I would ruminate on that one comment for
a day so part is a good thing you're not
on social media staff especially yeah
well yes yes although some day I might
plug back into social media to see if
I've stabilized approval on the inside
because that's the big idea the big
movement as we mature just mature as
human beings let alone become more
conscious is can I start to source
approval from the inside can i stabilize
a sense of okayness on the inside and
now you can tell me you didn't like that
or I imagined there could be people who
really don't like some of the stuff I've
said today and I can let you say what
you say believe what you believe that
the story you have and not lose my hip
because I'm stabilized in a sense of
approval that comes from the inside I'm
not just talking about self approval
here I'm actually talking about resting
in a field of acceptance so it's stable
I was trying to get security from the
outside
and you know literally money from the
outside wouldn't be my security fide
money then I was secure but it could be
safety from the outside this is a big
thing of what's coming up right now in
our world we are still sourcing safety
on the outside and therefore were
terrified when our safety gets
threatened and control you know I say to
people were all control freaks we try to
control everything that's another thing
that's coming up right now is so much is
in our face every day that is totally
out of our control and it's utterly
terrifying so in that simple one I just
go back to just sort the files what's
under your control what isn't under your
control place your attention on what's
under your control so again I come back
to as people do this journey toward
being a more awake alive empowered human
part of it is doing practices that allow
us to get a sense of approval control
security and oneness or connection on
the inside because that just take you as
you do that source that more and more
from the inside and then you come
towards your girlfriend and she's
sourcing it from the inside most
relationships aren't that way most of us
don't have enough of any of those so
we're like two ticks on a dog and the
relationship becomes a ship but we try
to suck approval control security and
oneness out of the relationship and of
course we all know where that goes but
if you come towards her as a relatively
filled up person and say hey listen I'm
pretty damn filled up and so I have
energy to give to the relationship and
he comes the same way now it's not like
two ticks on a dog it's like two people
dancing a dance that is quite powerful
and that's the difference between a
codependent and a co committed
relationship codependent to takes on a
dog Co committed were both committed
to sourcing approval control security
and oneness and aliveness and bringing
that to the relationship so I I would
want to say that that's an important
piece of growing up I think thank you
for that and I think this is as good a
time as any to announce that instead of
writing the notebook I'm actually
working on a novel and it's two ticks on
a dog a dystopian love story that is
that is not in fact what I'm working on
it's one I'm working against or working
to not have but Jim this this has been
so so much fun for me and I really
appreciate you taking the time I hope we
get to continue the conversation at some
point yeah you too Tim you know I
appreciated you you know from afar like
we joke you know a lot of stuff that
you're up to in life I'm not up to but a
lot of stuff you are up to I got in on
board with because of you and our mutual
friends so I'm profoundly grateful for
your willingness to keep risking that's
one of the stories I make up about you
you're willing to keep risky finding an
edge reinventing stepping over the edge
making a mess reconfiguring that's not
easy to do when you have you know as
much at stake as it appears you do so
your willingness to do that over and
over again has been a tremendous service
to me personally and obviously countless
other people but I'm grateful that
you're willing to do that Tim thank you
Jim that really means a lot and it means
a lot particularly right now I've been
struggling I'll be honest and I that
makes my day
to hear you say so thank you very much
and we'll continue risking and would
love to continue the chat about the
integrity inventory and other things
another time but
I think this is good for a round one and
people can find you certainly they find
all the social the the easiest way to
find everything related to the conscious
leadership group is that conscious dot
is which is is so as that that is the
website I will link to everything that
we've discussed all the books all the
concepts all the people everything
including your book the 15 commitments
of conscious leadership in the show
notes at Tim not blog forward slash
podcast you can find show notes for this
episode and every other episode and Jim
once again thank you so much for making
the time this has just been a real
pleasure and quite frankly a welcome
reset and recalibration for the compass
as I as I wander into the rest of the
day and this week hopefully with just a
little bit more groundedness and clarity
so I really give you a heart felt thank
you for that mmm you're welcome Tim
truly truly a pleasure and to everybody
tuning in thanks for listening and be
safe say I love you to the people you
love and thanks for listening in on yet
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is bible at friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email for me every
Friday event provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favourite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
Don come that's four hour workweek com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled LM NT what on earth is
element it is a delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix I've stocked up on
boxes and boxes of this was one of the
first things that I bought when I saw
coca coming down the pike and I usually
use 1 to 2 per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low-carb or paleo diet or if you
drink a ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
I drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise mountain biking
etc another application if you've ever
struggled to feel good on keto low-carb
or paleo
it's most likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting it up and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone
blah blah blah and insulin is low but
suffice to say this is where elements
against both lmn t can help my favorite
flavor by far is citrus salt which is a
side note you can also use to make a
kick-ass no sugar margarita but for
special occasions obviously you're
probably already familiar with one of
the names behind it Rob Wolfe ro BB Rob
Wolfe who is a former research
biochemist and two-time year Times
bestselling author of the Paleo solution
and wired to eat Rob creative element by
scratching his own itch that's how it
got started his Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
coaches turned him on to electrolytes as
a performance enhancer things clicked
and
company was born so if you're on a
low-carb diet or fasting electrolytes
play a key role in relieving hunger
cramps headaches tiredness and dizziness
sugar artificial ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element and a lot of names
you might recognize are already using
elements recommend to be by one of my
favorite athlete friends three Navy SEAL
Teams as prescribed by their Master
Chief Marine units FBI sniper teams at
least five NFL teams who have
subscriptions they are the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and on and on you can try
it risk-free if you don't like it
element will give you your money back no
questions asked they have extremely low
return rates
so again element LM NT came up with a
very special offer for you guys they've
created
Tim's Club just go to drink elements
dot-com / Tim select subscribe and save
and use promo code
Tim's Club to get the 30 count box of
element for only $36 this will be valid
for the lifetime of the subscription and
you can pause at any time so again check
it out it's drink LM NT calm / Tim for
this exclusive offer using promo code
Tim's Club one more time
drink LM NT element so drink LM NT calm
/ Tim and promo code
Tim's club check it out
[Applause]